das heißt dass sozen chaos geht also
ungebremst weiter freunde haben sie
gesehen
nur noch 16 prozent in den umfragen
natürlich auch wegen der endlosen
personaldebatten und von all dem
gescheiterten spd vorsitzenden ist
martin schulz für mich wirklich einer
der tragischsten oder das fast war doch
gar nicht mehr in nine der jetzt in elf
monaten von hero zur zero
so schnell geht das nämlich in diesem
grausamen business viele setzen jetzt
ihre hoffnung auf andrea nahles und
martin schulz ja herr schulze ist
erstmal jetzt weg nicht mehr da an einem
besseren ort kurz gesagt in würselen
meine damen und herren
aber haben sie gemerkt das ist gemerkt
sie sagt schon herr schulz nicht mal
mehr martin wie traurig ist das denn
oder
ansorg benutzt und weggeworfen liebe
genossen nichts gegen gute sündenböcke
aber wann kommt denn endlich der
vielzitierte inhaltlichen neuanfang der
spd neuer vizekanzler in spe olaf scholz
ist zum beispiel ein lupenreiner agenda
mann der gerade einen öffentlichen eid
auf die schwarze null geschworen hat mit
dem wollte jetzt die basis vom
koalitionsvertrag begeistert die spd
könnte von dem das hier erreicht hat
wirklich begeistert sein und dann auch
andere begeistern
ja absolut
denn ich sage mal wenn einer die
menschen begeistern kann dann prinz
valium von der elbe meine damen und
herren
aber das müssen wir sagen immerhin die
frau nahles ist keine schlechte wahl
manche sagen ein bisschen schrill
vielleicht aber dafür wenigstens
authentisch ist ja mal eine urgewalt
haben sie das mal gesehen wie die sich
freut hier aktiv bilder wo sie das willy
brandt haus abreißt mal auf mal ohne
witz jetzt ich bin die nicht schlecht
ernsthaft hat im letzten kabinett
wenigstens was weg gearbeitet die nadel
stichwort mindestlohn verheerend das
müssen wir so offen sagen verheerend ist
allerdings was wir bürger inzwischen
über die entstehung des neuen
koalitionsvertrag lernen mussten am
entscheidenden tag haben die 14 stunden
am stück nur noch über boston und
ressorts gestritten
was macht das denn für den eindruck hier
ein insider packt aus dann sitzen
verbleibenden dem zimmer 45 personen die
aber nicht miteinander reden weil keine
erlösung hat und weil man
unterschiedlicher meinung ist ich habe
dann gerne eine materie oder eine orange
geschält weil das leben mit betätigung
war
vielen dank ihr mandarine für diesen
einblick und in einem punkt meine damen
und herren sind sich ja inzwischen alle
einig die cdu ist der eigentliche
verlierer nur noch schrott ministerien
wie gesundheit oder bildung vor allem
aber musste die cdu den schlüssel zur
kasse abgeben das gute finanzministerium
das ist schmerzlich mit dem
finanzminister jetzt wo wir schmerzlich
gebe ich zu das finanzministerium nicht
haben schmerz den auch ich empfinde ich
hätte gerne das finanzministerium
behalten obwohl ich wusste und selber
fühle dass das auch schmerzhaftes bei
koalitions schmerzen und chronische
machtverlust mutti prof
[Applaus]